at least eight people including seven
children
and one teacher have been killed with 16
other people injured
in a mass shooting that's taken place at
a school in kazan
let's get more on this now from auntie's
daniel hawkins who's been
across this story alongside me during
the last
few hours the numbers have fluctuated a
lot and the information coming in
has changed over the last three hours or
so how do things stand right now
well tragically of course we might have
to update those those casualty figures
that have come in as we say the
situation has been ongoing since about
10 a.m
uh moscow time uh this morning so for
about two uh just over two hours now
the latest figures around 20 people are
in hospital with
various levels of injury
some of those people may have been
injured in the shooting by flying debris
tragically some may have been injured by
jumping from the windows of the school
as they tried to escape the horror that
was going on
inside initial reports came through
from authorities that one or two
shooters had entered this college school
number 175
in kazan central russia the capital of
the tatasta republic
eyewitness accounts described explosions
and gunshots and certainly the videos
we've seen from inside the school do
point to scenes of destruction and chaos
uh though those reports haven't been
confirmed of explosions inside the
school
authorities security services later said
there was only one attacker that entered
the school he came in on the first floor
on the ground floor uh as as you say in
the west
initially targeting the security uh
cleaners
before moving on to teachers and pupils
inside the school now
uh emergency services were very quick to
attend around 20 ambulances were on the
scene
um security services sealed off access
to the school
as parents tried to rush towards the
school to try and help their children i
believe we can bring you
uh some footage um of that uh taking
place right now just
warning the viewers obviously uh these
are distressing
uh and disturbing scenes let's take a
look at what happened in the moments
after
that incident
[Applause]
these uh scenes every parent's worst
nightmare obviously we can just imagine
what these
uh these families were going through as
they ran towards the school and
tried to find out if their child was
amongst those uh injured and involved
in what was going on now as i said
uh many casualties uh managed to escape
on foot from the school
and walking wounded so to speak others
had to be
carried out and receive first aid
treatment on the ground not a little
green area outside the school with
bystanders giving first aid
helping as they could until those
casualties were evacuated
in ambulances again this is distressing
footage um
let's take a quick look at those who
tried to do what they could for those
children
as they were evacuated from the building
well we're going to bring you that
footage just a little later as you can
see on your screen there we have uh
uh try to blur out the worst uh uh of
of those videos as we can see that is a
three or four story building that school
number 175 gymnasium number 175 and many
children were trapped on the top floors
unfortunately when the incident began to
take place
and we can see uh in that footage uh
some of them
decided to jump from the third or fourth
windows
again you can only imagine what horror
they must have been going through to
decide
to jump on the third or fourth floor as
opposed to stay inside
some of those can be seen and running
away from the school and
this footage we can show you we're
showing you now on your screens
is footage allegedly unconfirmed of the
suspect being
detained arrested by security services
we know in a lot of these cases
it ends up in a suicide by the gunman
by the attacker in this case he has been
detained and what we do know
from security services is his weapon his
firearm which he used in this case a
shotgun
was legally owned he had a license for
that shotgun he attended a local gun
club and in the days leading up to the
attack he purchased around 150
rounds of ammunition for the shotgun
again legally and
according to the law uh in russia that
would mean
a different set of charges as the gun
owner um if he
uh didn't own this weapon if it was
perhaps stolen or given to him belonged
to somebody else
it would be one thing uh he bears full
responsibility as the legal owner
of that rum uh in russia
and dan it's not a common story to hear
in russia of school shootings
um occasionally there have been
incidents though and this will get
people immediately thinking of one that
occurred what three years ago in
church yeah absolutely these incidents
aren't common
uh in russia when you think of mass
shootings or school shootings russia
generally isn't a country you think of
on the last one took place
as you say in 2018 in the republic of
crimea in the city of kirch
when a 1918 year old student vladislav
roslikov
went into a college with a firearm and
killed 20 pupils and teachers
60 people went to hospital before he
committed
suicide and that was the greatest loss
of life among children among students
and the biggest number of casualties
since all the way back in 2004
and the best land school siege of course
at events so terrible it's to this day
etched in the memories of
everybody across russia and
islamist inspired terrorist attack
this will of course bring back memories
of kirch 2018
the casualty figures thankfully with the
information we have coming in
aren't as high but any one loss of life
is already
too many and of course it's made a
little more tragic by um
the young loss of life we're seeing some
photos coming in unconfirmed
uh of uh pupils uh in that school
children in their teens we don't know
how old the attacker was
he perhaps maybe a former pupil at that
school
but it makes this all the more shocking
the the young loss of life
and the the age of the attacker if he
was a youngster um
thoughts is this a copycat attack could
this be inspired
by the church incident by a columbine by
other school shootings
we just don't know until security
services carry out the investigation and
see what the motive was
was it mental health a personal grudge
islamist inspired
we just don't know at this stage um and
security services do have the situation
under control now the attacker acted
alone we do know that
he has been detained they'll be looking
potentially for any other devices that
the attacker
either may have left or said he left in
the school
um they'll be searching his home
speaking to family members and seeing
what could have caused
this to happen